All right, let's go to our caller from the
eight zero one area code.
Who's calling today from eight zero one
David, is that me?
That is you.
Who's this?
Okay.
Isn't Ethan from Provo, Utah.
Hey, Ethan
also want a second Tommy from DC's.
Um, thoughts on razor fist.
Uh, that debate was another nail in the coffin
for any libertarian beliefs I had.
So shout out to cal Colin's.
Yeah,
I'll have to check that out.
Um, yeah, it was, uh, he got, uh, the Kyle
drivers, they say, but anyway, David, there's
a question I have.
This is like kind of going on in Utah Politics.
I don't know if you've heard.
So last election we had a proposition too
that was a, you know, you taught first medical
marijuana bill, right?
And it passed.
And since then, like the legislature stepped
in and I don't know how much Utah politics,
you know, but there's an insane, uh, Mormon
influence.
Yes.
That I know,
and a lot of, I mean, like looking at Romney,
so, so I mean, that's, I think Mike Lee as
well.
I mean, you know, so they're all in bed with
the church and they, and the church is like
at the table on any sort of legislative issues
that we got going on.
It's pretty insane.
Um, and so since the, since proposition two
passed, the legislators have been like, oh,
we're gonna like, we're gonna rewrite it because
it's like not good enough.
And they wanted it to be like, only pharmacists
can hand out medical marijuana, but like,
pharmacists can't do that because it's still
illegal.
Um, you know, federally, it's just a, it's
just kind of annoying here, David like being
a citizen because they also are doing this
with the Medicaid expansion.
Like, we'll vote on something and they'll
be like, ah, let us change it.
Like I like, what do we do?
Well, yeah.
Well listen, I mean, I, uh, I don't envy you
in the sense that I'm not looking to move
to Utah anytime soon, but is there anything
specific you wanted me to address today?
Um, yeah, so like, I guess the, uh, the question
I have, I hope this doesn't sound like I'm
just venting, but it's like, like what are
we supposed to do as, you know, like, what
am I supposed to do as a citizen?
We, when we get together as a state and like
vote on something and the legislators just
like, just kind of dragged their ass.
You got to work the grass roots.
I mean, this is what Republicans are so good
at.
If they fill state legislatures with people
that think exactly the way you're describing,
which you don't like, and we just have to
be as good as as they are at the ground game
and we're not, that's just the reality, whether
it's within or outside of the Democratic Party
and some, you know, local races, the partisan
side is less important than the ideological
side.
We've got to start building up that grassroots,
local, local election movement.
Listen, I gotta run, but I appreciate the
call and a bet.
Sounds like Utah's dealing with some serious
stuff there.
Um, I've never been, but I may be going, uh,
sort of soon for a wedding that is not a Mormon
wedding, interestingly enough.
Uh, okay.
That's it for today.
Sorry.
I know there were people I was not able to
get to, but uh, I will be streaming soon and
it will be another opportunity to take some
more calls.